[Musik]
das ich mache dies dass so eine art ist
dann ungefähr machen
willkommen zu einem video dass sie
endlich mal wieder mit max wieder mit
dabei und heute leute haben wir uns
gedacht welches video könnte diese
plattform verschicken eigentlich
eigentlich waren die leute heute ganz
war gefragt könnt ihr das vielleicht mal
machen ja unter jedem video so tausende
kommt mit einer million natürlich auch
mehr werden
heute bestimmen kannst du das machen und
macht heute leute heute reagieren wir
auf das was ihr euch jeden tag reinfall
wir als sterneköche leute sind heute
angetreten hier um euer essen zu
bewerten ihr habt uns zahlreiche bilder
eingeschickt wir regieren drauf wir
küren das beschissene essen das wir
sehen wir können das schönste essen das
wir sehen will ihn los haben in deinem
sinne von der station
der hat uns eine gebogene salzstange an
der stelle geschickt über ist der spaß
nicht wirklich verwirrt weil es dinge
sollte das ist für uns ist dass man so
bogen zur seite stand ja aber für 30
zentimeter große mini menschen ist es
halt ein gehstock
das kriterium ist natürlich auch ob es
auch im gehsteig für 30 cent könnten
wegen mico menschen weitergehen bis army
mein erster pfannkuchen ich heule und
die ganze sache sieht so aus ruß hat
also noch ein bisschen größer
perfekt von sicherheit eindeutig dass
der kuchen ließ auch sagen leute die
form vom kontinent afrika hat und das
allerwichtigste ist dabei dass man auch
mindestens zehn gramm kohle ja auch sein
pfannkuchen hatte die bestimmte noch so
holzkohle briketts oder sogar zum super
meisterschaft ist super da haben wir das
essen von china die hat das wirklich
optimal gemacht genau muss man das
machen ersten salat
und im körper sozusagen egal wer uns
ganz gesund heute kein problem und bart
ortes macarons alter 3000 kalorien nach
salzburgring salas besser den der von
julia julia schickt uns dieses mädchen
mit frühstück also ich muss sagen man
kann wirklich immer so schießen du sagst
mir jetzt nicht von neuen konstant das
ist jetzt nicht mehr dass es durch das
ist ein ganz so wollen das ist aber bei
dem bei dem restaurant so aber du warst
du brauchst mir da nichts sagen gehört
natürlich die muster ist geworden ich
habe mir gerade eben vor diesem video
eine packung schoko reiswaffeln und eine
packung räucherlachs reingezogen ohne
irgendwas damit zu machen ich es ist
einfach so [ __ ] carina schenkt
dieses bild hier kann man davon machen
wir zu posten die purzelbaum bild von
der ich finde dass das perfekte bild um
zu zeigen nicht jeder von uns perfekt
lieber das perfekt jeder hat seine
eigene marke manche von uns sind halt
verbrannt dafür kein loch in der mitte
manche sind normal und haben noch in der
mitte manche sind krank verbrannt unter
machen
okay okay ich ein bisschen musik ist
eine tonne class gestoppt das will ich
die leute meinten verbucht das klingt
alles recht diese schwarze banane ja
vielleicht ne ballade oder so was ist
denn der ofen bananen ist eine sache die
ich auch regelmäßig erste weil wir beide
arbeiten ja wieder auf den sommer zu
möglich definiert seinem strand ganz
klappen da muss man halt auch mal die
ein oder andere banane mit kinder
schokolade drin auch das ist einfach das
wirklich sich viele die zeit genommen
haben wollen keineswegs inzwischen zwei
davon so ein bild gemacht habe aber bei
einigen was tut man sich in so ein was
herzhaft würzigen obst decke wird es
dafür einen wies dieses foto endet dann
bestellt wird die kamera hier
damit hätte auch einfach ins netz
die man in der regel jeden tag ist ein
morgen einfach so morgens aufsteht und
die schule muss macht man sich halt
kurzem verlauten und glp minecraft kopf
klar ich würde sagen das ist unser platz
eins der schönsten heute auf jeden fall
ein kleiner junge mit zu geringem und
und hier leute für das essen gehen
werden die anfänge zurück
es ist einfach es ist praktisch und
jajaja gegenstand der ja das ist mal
nicht so was mach ich das ding war so
einmal unten ab dann kommt als die
zentimeter waren wir so abgestimmt er
nimmt den wind auf dem ballhofplatz
nutzerin gehstock seite einfach also zu
lassen kann